Harry Potter and the Order of the
Phoenix so this is the PS3 version
this is really they got back to their
Roots they made it open world again
which was a huge huge welcome change
after
what we just had to experience with
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
which made some just bizarre decisions
bizarre decisions all right
yeah this one when they finally had like
the proper Hogwarts
good good nice nice
perfect thank you guys
all right so it starts off oh my
goodness these
[Music]
the graphics
a step up
above what we just experienced in Goblin
that's just wrong deadly
that's just wrong
all right we are not in control yet it's
still controlling it
guys want to talk about bad mocap
you want to talk about bad uh
like the facial animations
here you go
press triangle to get your wand out
repeatedly move
so we just twirl it all right that's all
I'm doing I'm just I'm just twirling it
repeatedly move the right stick
did that take care of it
tomorrow
there we go
underage Magic cast in the presence of a
muggle
oh that made me so mad reading the books
made me so it's like come on really
you gotta be kidding me
it's a little bit low here we'll turn it
up
turn up just a bit for you guys
once he got his packing done it's a
little bit low in my ear too when
they're talking the music's loud but the
voices are a little bit low
oh my gosh he's like falling asleep
standing up right there what
headquarters of the order he called
Diddy kids right it's a secret society
the people who fought against Voldemort
last time I know dude the HDR 4K or a
tracing right 60 FPS solid I've been
doing nothing you've had all the fun
here here at the headquarters of the
order
it's not that exciting mostly we'd be
doing cleaning for mum Mrs Weasley is
very keen on cleaning could you give me
a hand I have to move all the stuff in
this room against that wall so mum can
clean the floor it's okay Harry you're
not at the dursleys now you're allowed
to use magic I recommend using Akio and
yes no emotions but I've not learned
those spells yet
first you need to aim at the chair we
actually get aiming in this game are you
kidding me
Okay so
pull down twice
all right now show me
again how do I aim though like
Jenny once more
all right I'm a little bit confused on
how we choose what we're aiming at maybe
it was just automatic for the is great
for the little lesson here
welcome
Co I know dude that's how they
pronounced it in Goblet of Fire
okay it wants me to up twice
actually all right that one makes sense
now let's deal with the Lost
we still gotta figure out the aiming
like hopefully there's some kind of some
sort of lock-on because everything from
over here
to over there that's right I thought
they were trying to clean
just made it so much worse okay there we
go press L2 or R2 to change targets
all right so Jenny hold on let me let me
figure this out here well okay Jenny
just just take it away
just take it away Jenny
all right so how do I actually see what
I'm locked on to
[Music]
huh
unfortunately the controls are a little
bit wonky in this one too
not very precise is how I would describe
it Jenny what are you what are you doing
thanks that might stop mum moaning for
five minutes inspector what's up
somewhere let's find them yeah I'm
hoping I won't need as much help on this
one inspector
how far games have come guys how far
caves have come when he heard about the
Dementors if I hadn't been stuck at the
dursleys hey bamboo welcome back
Molly drafted you into domestic duties
too Hermione I'm fixing these then we'll
give you one wait you're fixing what
repo is the spell for this job oh very
serious just teaching us everything
right off the Jump here real one like
this and say reparo
riparo
okay
wait what am I repairing
I guess I just need to cast it all the
plates
the plates I was like what am I
repairing
let's get this place tied it up Jake
Discord
oh yeah yeah I I
heard about that Nico
yeah guys the uh
if you don't want to be spoiled on
Hogwarts Legacy
on anything really the art book has is
out in the wild
it is out in the wild with a lot
a lot of content is in there so
kind of have to we will not be
discussing spoilers like that here so
if we see any in the chat mods will take
care of it don't I mean don't ban people
or anything you know because some people
might just hop in trying to discuss it
not knowing
not knowing which is okay you know but
we'll just we'll quickly hide the
comments as we can but yeah art book I
think the whole thing's been been
released there's actually somebody dming
me this morning Nico I didn't realize I
don't think I realized how widespread it
was
but yeah apparently it's out there in
the wild now maybe
if you see this spells worse both the
mouse and gamepad
I mean it was it worked right there yeah
you just kind of spin it
clockwise with the uh right analog stick
around
lucky Lupine taught you expecto patronum
yeah that's me lucky lucky I'm gonna get
exposed stopping a dementor
you'll be back at home Harry's just
frustrated but everything people say
Wingardium Leviosa the liftings
Wingardium Leviosa let me guess it's
going to be the other counterclockwise
oh my goodness wait what they're in the
air we can move just wiggling back and
forth
hold on I think it's like left right
oh wait what is the X for
all right so up left right left right
okay
Ron's mimicking it he's mimicking
exactly what I'm doing okay up
when guardian there we go there we go
all right that wasn't too crazy oh press
X to drop the clothes
come on drop it there we go
all right I pushed like up and then I
let go but you have to like hold it and
then go left right left right there we
go okay okay
not too bad
highly in Soldier hey oh Ryan last name
nice dude welcome thank you for stopping
by here guys yeah we were having a
twitch YouTube discussion earlier on the
morning stream
you guys are just dropping in we
streamed over on YouTube finished up
Goblet of Fire this morning now
afternoon stream here to start Order of
the Phoenix
Let's see we also had a new follow from
uh Rocky Boy Rocky boy thank you for
following there yeah you guys were
asking about the targeting I'm trying to
figure it out like it says L2 or R2
but
is my controller broken
okay Ron Ron Ron just like decided to
take that one
I'd get your mum to wash these wrong
what is going on here dude
mama's been automated side of this place
huh yeah I I I cannot see the faint
Target
it is not showing up it's a faint
glowing outline I don't know how stuff
gets that spread out Wingardium Leviosa
useful for moving things around sort of
similar to what they're doing in
Hogwarts Legacy that one's a little more
obvious
she says they can't expel you yeah what
were the Dementors doing there anyway
that is a very good question very good
question Ron I
dying of the order you stay and catch up
with your friends Harry
so if you guys are planning to uh
important
Dumbledore
I forgot about this one starting totally
before you get to Hogwarts
foreign
little invention
the audio is inconsistent too like now
that was that was really low right there
oh the Visions they're already beginning
it's more like a pulsating outline just
as visible
broken car headlights
oh we're already at the ministry okay so
that was like your little tutorial right
there at the beginning
as fudge
[Music]
oh boy there she is
there she is Dolores
okay so we skipped the trial and
everything gotcha
now it takes us to Hogwarts
[Music]
don't want to see her face
oh friend of fudges that's that's one
way of describing umbrage
[Music]
how annoying is she in the game man I
can't remember
if she bothers you too much in the game
worse than Voldemort I mean you could
make a good argument really
could make a very good argument
all right so we are here guys we have
made it to Hogwarts now see there I see
a little faint outline on Ron
Umbra thank you for following welcome
all right so now okay I could see the
little lighting much better here it sort
of flickers oh but it's like not even
when I'm walk locking on just when I'm
walking around so now you see that
little faint glow on the bench right
there Wingardium Leviosa there we go oh
my goodness can you just like knock
people out with this
you'd imagine
oh
whoops
okay okay set it down Harry set it down
all right there we go
all right camera's a little rough it's a
little rough did you hear nearly as Nick
earlier glad we've got the Bloody Baron
oh I didn't get to read it all
I did get to read it all
she doesn't really bother you in the
game okay good
hold down X to run okay all right so
that's how we run around
let's see what else can we do out here
I think we're supposed to go inside
right
hey Harry can you smell money
quiet George he might take points off us
anyway if you don't hurry up you'll be
finding Hermione in a bad mood
so what can we do not the brightest is
he always think it's so pathetic he
couldn't get his head chopped off
properly gotcha the Marauders map
yeah the Marauders map
that was one of the coolest things they
put in this game
uh press select button to open the
Marauders
yeah
this was so good
all right go to the Gryffindor common
room press X to select Hermione okay so
we just select her from the list there
uh press select to close the Marauder's
Map and then you get the little
footprints look at that look at that
look at that
kind of like show you the way
the entrance hall
can we not can I not look up here
uh rip rip today and Chris M welcome
guys thank you for following
I know there's a way to like
wait did that just lock on you can lock
on no no no I want to look
it just freaked them out
they just ran the other way no like
Harry come on dude I'm trying I want to
look up at the Statue
there's got to be a way you could look
see these games man they just didn't
want you to explore for whatever reason
let me try to come back
there we go okay I just wanted to get a
good look that's all
it just just wanted to get a good look
at the portrait
yeah the camera is very limited like
right stick isn't doing much of anything
except
look just making him
got the wand here
all right let's head this way I think
we'll beat Ravenclaw hi Harry uh hi Joe
well I thought I'd say hello there's Joe
did you have a good summer camera's
fixed inside and almost being expelled
uh is that a tornado's bad you don't
support them do you yeah the noodle arm
yeah see you later Harry
yeah I saw bins had some videos
comparing to some of the old games
kojo welcome game is your favorite out
of the whole series hope Hogwarts like
he's tough set I hope so too yeah
let's get to the color I mean just like
even if they just took
even if it looked was like this exact
layout and everything but just updated
Graphics of today I mean that alone
would be so fun to go through and
explore
all right so we got all the little
portraits here and I know we can hold
down X to run I'm just kind of taking it
all in right now
floor one
now this game I will say they did a
great job they had all of these like
fan councils and stuff that they put
together they really listen to people
for this game whenever I was working on
my video the complete history of
the Harry Potter video games I came
across a lot of that
wait he doesn't want to let me in we
can't talk to him
we can't
hey Mary how's it going
yeah this is the one where
Harry and Cho the infamous date at
madame puttyfutz
got the fat fryer there flying by does
he hurt me let's see okay no I didn't
all right so you can't go in there all
right let's go ahead and run
lore4
all these rooms are locked right now
dude just the controls man this game
would have been it would have been so
much better if they just
is that George Washington
wait who who are you sir
oh we can't talk to him for some reason
sir Duggan right there looks like
oh you're not very pleasant
oh my goodness we just had wait what one
two three four hydrates back to back to
back oh goodness that's a lot of drinks
right here
thank you guys for the hydrating that is
a lot of hydrating
I gotta save some man
save a little bit of my Cherry Coke Zero
oh there she is the fat lady
so it looks like they did the same
layout that the movies had
Movie 3 changed her location so see how
she's just like right there at the top
of the stairs instead of being at the
end of the corridor
[Music]
why they changed that it's fun for this
movie
oh great you don't you really don't
remember okay so we have to find someone
else
and ask if they remember the password is
that what Ron just said
yeah how could you not know Ron come on
hey can I talk to you dude do you know
hi
[Music]
thank you
now move it right oh my gosh
wait what Ron was not a bully
are you kidding me right now
when did Ryan become a bully
wow
you been
forgot the password Hermione
notice board okay yes
this was something they had in the uh
use your magic uh can we just do deposo
maybe
there we go nice
what are those
oh is that the ancient Magic
the ancient magic orbs
Myrtle uh well I'm becoming a prefix
changed man
there are things all over Hogwarts that
can be discovered you should look for
them
only this time it'd be full of spiders
was he a bit of a boy man it's been a
while since I've done a reread
you mean is another chamber not to
chamber more of a room I found it when I
was hiding in the pipes
every time someone makes a disco
special things appear in the room
special secret
wait where is this room of rewards oh
yes
ask Myrtle metal will tell you yeah I
wonder why they chose Myrtle for this
instead of Nick or something
have to discover it for yourself this
game made everyone rude serious
complaining about Molly in the practice
round
thought the rewards room was such a well
thought out gameplay mechanic for
Collectibles dude I don't remember any
of this uh unbelievable isn't it I
played this one pretty extensively too I
can't believe he got double potions on a
Monday we better find Neville I bet he's
not looked at the timetable yet and
we've got Umbridge for defense against
the dark arts next maybe this is a time
to check your map okay check the map
just look how small this common room is
though let's just let's just take that
in for a second
and when oh okay I didn't know you you
could just climb right on top area there
we go
that's one of the things that's going to
be so fun about exploring Hogwarts
Legacy just the common rooms alone I
mean look at this is that it
there's like this and surely you could
go upstairs over here
oh my goodness what is this weird
Resident Evil one style camera right
here
okay yeah is that the girls side
all right you can't go in there in
either of those just yet it seems
hey let me back let me back down Ron
all right and it looks like there's all
sorts of things
oh yeah Dylan that's what I was just
like there's all sorts of things we can
interact with in here
sorry sorry
crook shanks
all right let's see
all right Dylan said when guardian
Leviosa on the logs
all right so right here
oh no oh yeah there we go nice get the
little fire going
and there we go we just collected more
we're just going to call them ancient
magic orbs I don't know what they're
actually supposed to be called
Ron's just like dude come on oh and then
they've got the these guys playing
wizard chess over here hello
how are you
all right Ron wanted us to get the map I
gotta give him credit also like even
though I wanted to explore for a little
bit there like in the old games if you
explore for two seconds
Ron is always like come on Harry come on
Harry what are you doing we gotta go
Harry just over and over drives me crazy
this game Ron he's like you know what a
movie page
all right but what does he wanted me to
do he's
hit the map
what do you want me doing with the map
Ron oh we got to go to defense against
the dark arts and we also have
okay we're gonna meet Neville along the
way so I'm just gonna go ahead and Mark
Umbridge here
and then we'll go find her
can we go yeah
oh look at the little snitch is that in
the oh that's in the portrait right
there
making sure my webcam is not covering up
too much of the game for you guys all
right so I don't think was there
anything else we could really do or
interact with on the board right now I
don't think so
yeah
he learned he learned Mary
also nice that there's no immediate load
screen I know that there are load
screens at some point in this game but
all right so we're at floor six
found wall
we did I mean I just just walked out
years
oh for that power to jinx that Minx what
do you want or very late you are an
offense to the eye you can catch the
snitch so it's not in the portrait
oh that's fun
I'd like to go into the room of rewards
and if wishes grew on trees oh
pester someone else do I need a password
I said push off push off
oh we could stay here until Myrtle comes
back Myrtle likes Harry I'm sure he was
very exhausting in the older games very
exhausting either we could go inside
died or Harry could ask Myrtle to haunt
you loved All the Small Things
really started to put a lot of Secrets
and stuff
oh my goodness who is this portrait man
he is so unpleasant
all right so we'll follow the Little
Footsteps here and that was such a great
mechanic too
I know people don't always like it when
it just spells out exactly right where
you should go
but just having it like this with the
Little Footsteps something that's just
so fitting
all right third floor Neville's gonna be
just outside here I saw somebody saying
we should definitely find Neville first
all right so he should be through here
yeah I know we can hold down X to run
just kind of just exploring a bit
oh I recognize those things
oh can I not cast spells right here
come on
I can't accio it either what
okay no
nope
wait how about this looks like you can
lock onto that
no beans
nobody bought beans
are you kidding me
incendio
oh do I need to learn wait what was
reperto hold on hold on I think it was
yeah there we go
yes or ancient Magic
all right 30 collected we need 40 to the
next upgrade all right there wasn't
anything in here was there that I needed
to uh
reperto I forgot about that one
and also is there anywhere like a a log
or something that tells me spell list
here we go
it's like there's gotta be a way oh we
don't so we don't know incendio yet can
we use to set an object on fire reducto
can be used to smash an object so we
just have the first four right now
and then if I click on it does it
actually show me oh this I was gonna say
I'm probably going to be forgetting some
of these
no beans only crests uh
so the footprints on the floor that's
like their system that they used for um
like when you mark an item on your map
a point of Interest
hold Circle for Discovery View
wait is that supposed to be like first
person or something what in the world
what
why am I looking at
why why is it zooming in on Harry's head
for Discovery View
yeah pero
hey
that's kind of cool
all right got a couple more right there
let's see now we need what 20 more yeah
20 more
all right let's try maybe a Wingardium
Leviosa and we can re-hang these or
something
oh this is a little this is a puzzle
right here
okay so let's put that right there
okay this one
gonna go right here like see stuff like
this is so cool if it just if it just
worked a little bit better like the
controls are a bit
maybe that will work I don't know
nope not over there Harry right here
uh May strix welcome thank you for being
here
oh no we got him
we gotta move a little bit
I can't see
okay but it's got to be the bottom one
because the head is the other part
yeah there we go
all right and then last
nope not you
here we go
whoa the controls
it's just like flying by
nice there we go
your spells are now more powerful
completed Discovery level one hello
Myrtle
can't even get into the room
I can't get into it
posture check redeemed
we're pretty good on posture right now I
feel like we're in the uh
we've got my desk in the standing
position so I do need to bend my knees a
little bit more though they feel they
feel a little uh a little tight wait is
that a wizard card on the floor oh it is
hold on she's look the chocolate frog
right there do you want to play a game
of exploding snap exploding snap play
apparently as you level up the controls
become easier yeah I wonder how that's
going to work like how is it going to
make them more powerful I mean I guess
they're just stronger the casting was
probably the same right
L when Redeeming the hydrate right there
all right press X or Square when you see
a matching pair
so wait then when do I push forward
though
like after I see the matching pair
okay you need to beat six
okay
so I just have to press X really quickly
when I see a match
there was one of those in there
what
is this just a game like testing
reflexes do they have to be back to back
I'm so confused
back to back okay when I see him back to
back
so it's just like a reflex thing I guess
okay that green dude
okay
giant squid dragon
a green dragon Commonwealth green maybe
another troll
another giant squid giant squid
got it all right
so I guess you can hit any of the
controls they were saying I'm gonna try
a different one this time
there it is
all right so either one of them work
I should have just talked to that
portrait
oh will he will he let you if you just
talked to him he was just being such a
jerk
okay this is kind of cool it's getting
faster
he was being such a jerk I didn't think
he was gonna let me in
oh
all right there's no way she can come
back right
oh there was one
oh that was one right there right there
right there yes
yes goodness it's so fast now
oh no I messed up
do I lose points if I get it wrong
she didn't do anything like she didn't
try the whole best score six how many
did I get
you scored six
okay do what do I win what happens she
didn't get any
oh if you mess up too many times you you
won
how did you win
hatches
what
oh oh no we're playing hi Harry yes yes
I do you you didn't get any matches
well you have to beat
you guys really retro they got the
instructions right here you just you
just need to read just read the
instructions you can do it I promise
okay okay beat six beat six gotcha
gotcha and don't miss is it negative
though if you get one wrong
that's what I need to know if it's
negative if you get one wrong
oh my gosh it takes forever at the
beginning there we go there's one
snap
okay I could see why people are sad
stuff like this it's not in Hogwarts
Legacy
I could see I could see people like just
spending a lot of time on this trying to
beat high scores and such oh there we go
another one
foreign
yeah I see the cards explode but
sorry I can't talk too much
I don't think if you lose points if you
mess up okay okay gotcha Health Puff
oh another one
oh it's speeding up
there we go
all right we're gonna destroy your score
this time what's like the max you can
get
right there
I think we've already got six B
oh I missed one
get the troll get the troll
oh my goodness
no oh
I guessed I totally guessed on that one
do I get the match on that one no the
last one exploded too
all right that's more than six
oh barely though barely
barely I thought I was destroying it
gets hard at the end
it does get hard at the end
again yeah that was pretty fun
not gonna lie
all right so now we're heading to
Umbridge oh there's Neville
he's so much taller in this one oh is
this like our first duel
get him Harry
wait what
oh our R1 now all of a sudden
oh just pointing our wand is enough
you're like oh that's Harry Potter
that's Harry Potter dude thanks
I tried to stop them all you have to do
is point the wand but they start to
start to better get to defense against
the dark hearts
come on Neville all right so R1 is just
like
he just draws the one that's why those
those uh the girls ran off earlier
remember and I was like why do they just
I just trying to look at the Statue and
he gets close and they just took off
running
I think it's because I pressed R1 oh we
can examine this
this is one of the secret passages which
leads to Honey Dukes shame some of the
passengers are blocked now a one-eyed
Witch's House
how would you like to clean them oh I
wouldn't well I'm not ourself your bed
never got bullied by first years I know
dude
Neville has a great storyline though it
ends
very nicely
oh wait what is this oh cut scene okay I
thought it was wanting me to
thought it was Shifting the camera view
to just do that as we ran up
R1 is a battle spells mode you can later
on just hit students with battle spells
while being in this mode okay
interesting oh what is this
the little winged bore
can we interact with you at all
oh dude
he started he locked onto them
yo Harry
oh here we go
is here we go with the uh
they don't want you exploring all right
fine Hermione I get it I get it
okay wait is this umbrage nope that's
just a broom cupboard
the broom cupboard there
all right this one might be painful our
first class with Umbridge
puddle at the bottom of the stairs we
can clean with a mop
nice I'll have to look for that here
after we leave
oh dude that's creepy
oh she's creepy in the game
imagine why you would need to use
defensive spells
oh I don't know maybe because we're on
Voldemort's back
it's not alive oh goodness
I fought him Harry now wasted any time
just not wasting any time
letting Umbridge know everyone
I don't know about the owls on Hogwarts
Legacy that's a good question maybe help
us practice spells and owls here that's
what you're upset about not that a
teacher is telling everyone I'm a liar
where is it they've already done he is
not having it in this game man
real magic
salting Ron's brothers are you kidding
me
all right so well that went
not good do I need to take this mop all
the way down
no way right
no way you have to like carry it all the
way down hopefully there's an is it
gonna roll all the way
imagine if it just rolls all the way
down the steps
so funny
that's what I'm running wondering oral
is if they had
that's the exact question I was going to
ask like when did owls officially start
right
because if they did is there one back
there
oh no I think we actually have to bring
that broom
I think we actually have to if we have
to break that fruit all the way down
hopefully it's still there
that's kind of cool the stained glass
since we are Faith using Hogwarts let's
see must be owls on the way
yeah unless they just hadn't hadn't
started them yet you know like unless
owls weren't a thing yet because as far
as I know do we really know when they
started doing owls at Hogwarts
there we go just keep rolling
keep rolling
oh I just heard it I think it did oh
it's still going let's go
oh my gosh did people actually figure
this out
I could see if there was one right
beside it but
I'm gonna do all this work and then you
guys are gonna be oh yeah there was one
right beside it you just didn't even see
it
like what if it was right around the
corner here
oh dude imagine
oh my gosh they're so getting in my way
all right let's clean see look at this
Harry just doing a nice job here there
we go
are you trying to help out filch
good man Harry good man
all right 100 collected 130 to the next
upgrade
since the 1800s they have owls
oh no wait we just had back-to-back
differences
Wiki has an info on the earliest owl
exam in 1989 or you mean 1889.
1989 that would be
that's like really close to Harry's day
1989.
all right so friend George there's the
Bloody Baron Brett and George are in the
I don't need to look at the map Ron I
don't need to look at the map relax you
just relax
just just be quiet Ron oh wait you want
me to go back this way okay
no wait what what
they're outside
right here
might have been a raven didn't catch a
good Glimpse I gotcha
yeah guys just like a lot of the
moderators too are very sensitive to
spoilers for the game so that's why
we're just being extra cautious
some people literally don't want to know
like anything other than the official
stuff
I'm not one of them but we're just
trying to be respectful of those people
who are so
it's all good no worries don't don't
like feel like you're
you're not in trouble or something if
you had a had a message that got deleted
we're just trying to protect those
people
and the lighting is really weird right
here in this section really really weird
215 collected 15 more okay
oh yeah you're it's all good Dave yeah
yeah don't
don't feel bad
some people are just have like zero like
they don't want to know anything and
being
like part of this fandom seeing how
like growing up in this fandom like some
people do not want to know anything
for the books that was I was right there
with you man I'll never forget the uh
that video
by the way spoilers guys for uh Harry
Potter and the Half Blood Prince if you
haven't seen it
snake kills Dumbledore
there was a uh
a YouTube video of these people driving
by a bookstore just yelling that out and
people who were like I don't I think
they had just bought the book they were
like leaving the bookstore I always
wondered if that was faked it's like I
kind of hoped that was faked that's just
so brutal
oh brutal
but it looked legit
it looked legit from what I remember
okay so we're just going right back to
where we were which is fine but
you're a wizard Harry
you're a wizard Harry J Knight hey my
friend thank you for subscribing to the
channel
enjoy the ad free viewing here on the
channel and access to the emotes
oh yeah that's a good point Dylan yes
that's a good point so if you do want to
discuss spoilers guys yeah yeah we do
have a section on our Discord
we do have a section in the Discord
where you can post all the spoilers you
want look on your map which double check
with the uh
double check with mods
on the
I can't remember I think we might have
just renamed that section
but it used to be called hogwartsy
Hogwarts Legacy spoilers but I think we
might have renamed it something
can't think about that I'm worried about
Fields I'm sure he knows they were my
dumb boss
dude
um
Legacy Secrets thank you weird Chimera
yes yes that's it that's it so
exclamation point Discord in the chat
there if you guys aren't part of the
Discord
because I know some people love
disgusting the spoilers so we did want
to make a section for those people too
okay we can do a repair right here
raparo
appreciate the no ads I know and you
have uh if you're so if you're
subscribed on
twitch then it's totally no ads which
unfortunately there are quite a few
normally can I do hold on
so I don't want me to cast on this there
we go
and if you have Amazon Prime you uh you
can link it to your Twitch account and
then you get a free subscription so you
can use that on any anybody you want
things I was literally just there Myrtle
literally just there
it's not that many new things come on
I know the background chatter is so good
all right and then just a little puzzles
like these like we've got another
portrait here
all right so right over here is where
they're going
controls are just very very
kind of wonky right there
on getting it to go to the right spot
okay we need to flip it around
wait what is that I think that's bottom
left
bottom left Maybe
okay then we see the other part of the
face no no no no put you back put you
back
okay how do I get him to look down oh
wait that's totally gotta be a secret
right there too right
I honestly didn't know
let's go dude what do I get for it
anything oh examine examine
dude we're gonna be super powerful
Prince was better you think that one's
better High Q Warrior I never played
that one
I actually never played that one when
guardian Leviosa
but I want to after we beat this one
so we played a whoa what is
dude it just like flew to the ceiling
hold on get it get it back down Harry
there we go right there okay
wow okay well they're not very straight
hopefully I don't lose points for that
nice okay perfect
all right raise it up raise it up and
down right there
there we go
was that Ravenclaw
there she is
I'm pretty sure that's her right
wait what the heck happened
oh that's how you discover the house
ghosts
the gray lady that's awesome
I had so much benefits in the game he
won't spoil it for me
it had so much benefits
wait what did the uh
look on your map we can find them the
house ghosts
oh my goodness I just want to go
exploring all this stuff
do you want to go exploring
or are you talking about Half Blood
Prince
Gigi
lady great lady this dude's still asleep
he's not waking up for anything
HEPA Prince felt a little repetitive
quidditch was awesome though they didn't
have quidditch in this one did they
I know they brought it back for Half
Blood Prince I can't remember if they
had it in this one or not
all right we will finally go to Fred and
George
we will finally go you guys have been
not you the chat you Ron and Hermione
have been screaming at me even we even
got Nick dropping in
we got Nick dropping in on uh
Nick dropping at me like guys uh you
gotta you need to go to the Courtyard
here meet up with Fred and George
there they are okay
what do you want Harry all right we're
here
let's do this it's Umbridge she won't
teach us anything practical in defense
against the dark arts we heard so you
want our help
with this sorry look we better start
with the basics dude Dylan you remember
this game very well I see my sort of
opponent very well cats demonstrate
George I'd be delightful are we going to
learn expelliarism
we'll let it slide exactly
joking class now let's see you do it
Harry you remember if this Rivals
inspect I can tell Dude I can tell
Harry would already be I mean you guys
know he just literally like used the
spell to get away from Voldemort just a
few months before this took place right
right you guys know that right
well done you even got run to cast it
correctly get lost
when it comes to walking the smile off
the face of a Slytherin there's nothing
quite as good as stupid as stupid fire
is that gonna be up up let me guess
oh no it's the counterclockwise okay
no let's see you do it Harry just
imagine I'm Malfoy
I love that Harry is going to be the one
teaching these to everybody later in the
game
but he's got to get a quick crash course
from Fred and George first right bad not
bad at all white bus has been spotted
we're busy man nice place to go that's
such a cool marketing idea no spells
when you get a chance but who should we
practice on oh any passing Slytherin
will do see you later keep passing
slither.io and you better go to your
detention
I already got detention didn't I see you
later I already got detention
dang it
looking for
truck is that Draco
Mr Malfoy
is that Malfoy I I actually have no idea
oh okay wait
oh yeah
hold on it didn't make him drop the wand
why didn't he drop the wand
and why why is it going around him
there we go
it's like going perfectly around him oh
now we disarm him now we disarm him
[Music]
Harry what
what oh
no
okay there's Stupify
for some reason I guess you have to back
away from him a little bit
oh just keep hitting him with stupefy
when he's on the ground
okay there we go stupefy
what
okay there we go there we go
thank you Jay
you gotta be closer
or get like right up in their face
get close to him and expelliarism that
also works
experimus when they are prone
finish them faster gotcha yes for
telling the truth when Spider-Man had
the trains decked out for PS4
I don't remember seeing those but I'm
sure they were cool
Tom Felton oh did I do it Tom Felton
if I did a draco impression it was
totally just uh off the cuff
on bridge made Harry do that
you've got to tell Dumbledore about this
no this made me so mad in the book when
he wouldn't tell Dumbledore
let me guess
we have to go to the library
is she allergic to books right to the
library we go you down there
into the library press the like button
to open the Marauders map I solemnly
swear that I am up to no good
oh nice so now we can view the locations
over here
uh use up or down to find the library in
the list we were just at the library
oh dude they got everything in here nice
potions prefix bathroom I wonder if it
is as expansive I know I passed the
library don't worry I'm just looking to
see what all we have
all the viaduct and the viaduct entrance
okay and then we're back to The
Boathouse nice
yeah the prefix bathroom in the fourth
one my goodness
just absolutely crazy
what all they included in there all
right
to the library we go
however spell changes every game I know
and especially this one they they just
changed up the controls
quite a bit if we go to the second
oh
Specter stupefy spell splits because of
your level UPS from discoveries with
more level UPS it'll get more beams that
hit the opponent
I see and in some ways at all right yeah
I was about to say RPG like it kind of
makes it worse
if the spell doesn't shoot where you're
aiming it
are you serious
no Myrtle not again
why do they want me to go in here so bad
okay wait I think we have to yeah go
over here okay so not you is there a
secret pass
boy
but only those bearing the Hufflepuff
colors or the password may enter here
right
the Hufflepuff colors
you can learn his too oh interesting
you're probably going the wrong way
aren't I
okay there's the entrance hall all right
all right all right is this the Great
Hall can we go in here yet
please I want to see it oh
yeah
yes dude it's so awesome
Specter and Dylan are like oh we've lost
them now we've lost them
we've lost it I gotta look around I just
gotta look around here for a second guys
just a second I want to see the little
counters over here let's go Gryffindor
in the lead right now
Slither in a close second ravenclaws oh
man ravenclaw's gotta step it up though
can you actually can I win Guardian
double doors
no way dude
look at the physics on it too it's just
like it just goes crazy
Jay Knight
thank you for the chat there second
floor portrait yeah I think they were
saying uh second floor
all right all right all right we'll make
our way back make our way back hold on
can I wait wait can we can we play
wizard chess with you hello
why will I play you Potter you haven't
even played that Gryffindor loser that
plays for your house
the Burns in this game oh my goodness
any chance I could borrow your history
of magic essay
I fell asleep in the last lesson no
sorry
he's like nah you gotta play
I guess he's referring to Weasley here
that was uncalled for for real dude
for real totally uncalled for all right
Great Hall is awesome
well I'm just like also appreciating the
joy of no loading screen let's hex them
talk about the mud Bloods are you
serious right now what
all right so second floor
let's not Hermione let's not
all right so all right second floor
we're officially on the second floor
wrong
oh this is gonna be fun all right how
about this how about
maybe if we Mark something
it will lead me to it
I don't think we can Mark a person right
now yeah because we don't have any tasks
right past the Hufflepuff portrait guy
where the heck was he
I think it did you straight okay we're
good there he is dude wizard all right
all right maybe he will let us use yes
Passage
and a sub right there dropping from our
buddy Nico also known as Rey attire over
here on Twitch thank you Nico very much
appreciated my friend
Nico a long time long time subscriber
here
enjoy the emotes and to add free viewing
inquisitive mind
your deduction is correct I do so I've
never seen you
though I only allow those who are Keen
of mine
you mean in a test indeed I wish you to
assist me no no question for knowledge
came from
simple tasks
I didn't get too lost in Ragnarok
but I haven't I haven't done like my
full uh
trophy run yet
all right so what did he say chat I
wasn't listening I was reading I was
reading chat
okay wait he said I need to find a first
year Ravenclaw
is it just random like do we just
are they in a specific spot
he did it it only took
three times as long as it should have
okay short Ravenclaw student
hey what why are you going into that
weird camera view
how do you know how tall they are
they're all sitting down
oh both in the entrance hall okay
I was like how am I supposed to know how
tall they are
how do you guys all there everybody's
seated
you maybe this guy over here
hi can you tell me the password for the
portrait of Gifford Abbott he said I had
to help hey Dave have a good one thank
you for hanging out
dude let's go thanks that's not a raven
call though was it that was a Hufflepuff
one
all right so now we know the Hufflepuff
that that Hufflepuff password
it's for the other one okay is it you
hey you come back here you hey do you
know where Rowena Ravenclaw came from
yeah of course it's funny she's taller
now she's on the stairs thanks
okay now
let's see if I can make it back up to
that guy let's see if I can make okay
all right hold on
I think in my defense in my defense
like the camera does like spin around
quite a bit like as you're going up the
stairs okay so we're gonna go over here
though
okay there you are yep it's a right at
that dude
oh look at that look at that
okay very quick very quick
next time simply say studious success
studious success all right studious
success a healthy mind is an inquisitive
mind all right so he's gonna take we're
gonna go out down below right
oh yeah right here where the where these
rugs are
I don't think we can get any more
out of them right
now the footprints will always take you
here if you need to get to the library
instead of them
dude that's clutch that is actually
clutch right there
that is actually clutch
chat leading the way on that one
are you well
I'm supposed to get up there I don't
remember oh come on accio hello
Akio Hermione are you are you serious
I'm gonna actually have to climb this
oh goodness camera
oh goodness the camera okay hold on
come on Harry I need you to look up at
the book
I need you to look look up at the book
come come on
come on look look up at the book
and guardian Leviosa can be used to lift
and move an object
should have been on YouTube so when that
could rain
she finished up her uh
all right but what good does this do
I know we can cast him and you like lift
it up to knock it down or something
I guess we can climb it if we can
position it just right
not like that
bro you're in a magical school you know
the accio spell
why why
why
must it be this painful
oh my goodness dude
just sit it down Harry there you go
oh my goodness there it goes there it
goes
wait it's actually just going right back
to the same one oh okay I was gonna say
dude
for crying out loud
why why
you're doing great
I'm you know who I'm really disappointed
I'm really disappointed in Hermione
really disappointed
I mean they they should have at least
had a line where it's like
accio won't work in the library because
blah blah blah
they put some you know
some charm to make it so you can't use
accio on books in the Restricted Section
and we'd be like okay
oh are you kidding me you've got to be
kidding me
nice okay just gonna just gonna relax
there
imagine if it moves again
we can check this book isn't the right
book that was
this isn't the right book
oh my goodness dude
greetings is that all you have to say
how about you sorry I've agreed to play
the Slytherin Champion next I can't pay
you unless you were to beat him first
why did she think it was it was the I
mean because you're not could you not
read it no air blimey if it isn't Harry
Potter read all about your eyes
everything always in the paper you are
uh yeah
you are not true not true I seem black
and white in it got to be true man it's
been days since I've seen a paper yeah
can I use the shortcut behind your
portrait oh no no staff only Mike I
could make an exception you tell me what
the headline of the daily profit is
today and I'll let you through all right
oh my gosh
headline of the daily profit
hey Dylan thanks for being here dude
appreciate your tips as well have a good
one
all right so we have to find somebody
reading the paper probably
I'm gonna guess Great Hall for that
hello monster book of monsters
oh we can just you just Waltz right into
the restricted okay
all right
didn't know that
I didn't know that but there we go
how's it going Clint
yeah we beat goblet this morning so on
to order of the Phoenix we go
all right so I'm torn I'm like do I do I
want to learn the daily profit thing
right now
I mean I'm already in the library so I
should probably just go ahead and do
I should just do what we're here for
first
which is what
what is our
current task
oh back to Myrtle's bathroom okay
or is that for the portrait
either way that's what we're gonna do
that's what we're gonna go
okay gotcha nice and it takes me to this
guy
studious success you may pass Mr Potter
thank you sir
portrait can be done a bit later nice
you see that's why these footprints
are in this game literally for people
like me
so I could just mark it
and then follow the steps let's go I
know some people hate that too some
people hate having a little tracker like
in-game
Sports aren't necessary yeah yeah yeah
help you get around quicker I like that
though that's kind of a that's a pretty
cool mechanic
and I guarantee what are we going to be
able to do like incendio on that at some
point
instead of just being able to you know
get down and crawl crawl under
oh I love these little things right here
hi hello there
sorry don't mind me I'm just just
re-hanging some portraits here
to help out our buddy filch okay wait
where are they supposed to go is it
right here
like the coloration isn't as
obvious right here
I mean right here nope okay
on this side Maybe
before you write what you're just
thinking do you want spoilers for Half
Blood Prince or not oh for the game Half
Blood Prince I I don't I don't care
about Half Blood Prince spoilers for the
game yeah I think we're fine on that
RPG but thank you for asking yeah
yeah like which wall does it go on oh
right there I see it I see it now
all right so oh my God
oh my goodness that was talk about with
feeling Harry
what a great cast
he's like just casually hanging up these
portraits in Hogwarts oh my God I'm
Leviosa
Ron's like dude you know we're not
fighting a troll right now right relax
bro
why can I not
oh dude the camera is really rough man
it's really rough
oh wow it actually went to the right
spot somehow
I can't even see what this one is the
angle doesn't matter good good
because otherwise we would be in trouble
okay I think that one's gonna be this
bottom right
oh this is fat fryer isn't it
foreign
there we go and the last one
no Harry look down
yeah inspector it's pretty it's pretty
forgiving so even though the controls
are very loose it's very forgiving if
you if you're in the ballpark it usually
works
from what I've seen basically the
portraits and haploid prints are just
unlocked as you go along the story
without you having to do anything oh
interesting I wonder why they went back
on that
that's actually something I like just
kind of starting out here I know we're
pretty early but
yeah I sort of like that
all right so we are heading back to
Myrtle's bathroom
I wonder if all the house ghosts will
have their own side quests and Hogwarts
Legacy ooh that'd be fun wouldn't it
have we already talked to this one let's
see
sleeping okay so I guess if they're
sleeping does that automatically mean
they're a like a secret passage one and
you have to find
you have to go in and find their other
counterpart oh we can repair this
can't unlock them yet gotcha
oh they're talking about the secret
passages
I bet there are thousands
very cool
man this area is really cool
oh wait I just realized
hold on I messed up
Footprints where are you leading us
okay
oh wait when did I take a wrong turn
oh we're there nice
I know I just get so sidetracked looking
at everything in this game
that finally he realized I bet Umbridge
had it put there finally he's practicing
any more spells come
on yes it says here that you need to aim
your wand then simply tap it like this
and use the incantation
I think we'll be able to use that to get
into some additional areas
okay up down up down
oh you can use them to light these
little
just in here
one more lamp
wait oh the lamps in here I was like
wait we just did it
lock on up here dude the lock-on is so
weird
how do I lock on
there he goes he has to stand right
beside it and then he kind of looks up
nope look up Harry
nope nope not at the toilet not at
toilet
come on look up Harry oh my gosh dude
yeah but like
oh I guess you just have to keep tapping
it like that inspector
oh that is weird that's so different
than how games handle it now
oh but that actually I mean it does
technically
it does work
like he's just like
you just L2 R2 all the way around okay
so we got those two lit
we got that one lit
what in the world does it want us to do
on this
all right I guess there's nothing else
in there
all right oh we got one more Hermione
is that it
uh got that one got that one oh still
one more
oh two more
or is it timed are they going out
I guess we got it
oh she is not happy
foreign
[Music]
get them opened up
High metal
looks so depressed hi Motel are you
gonna make us take it it just lowers His
Head Library
but we borrowed so it's not as if we're
doing anything wrong
I'll keep hold of it let's get back to
the common run we need to get ready for
our hogsmeade visit
morning Myrtle your type of woman
serious so Umbridge is causing trouble
Dumbledore is using Hogwarts to form a
wizard Army I remember I was so
disappointed with the animation for that
in the movie
pictured it in the books at all
what are we supposed to do
foreign
got serious
what am I supposed to be seeing here oh
we're starting the Army already dude the
story is going really quick
[Music]
really quick man
I'm up here we need to find Neville
let's find Neville
we need to find Neville let's find
Neville all right Dylan's already gone
but Dylan was saying something about we
can catch
the snitch
oh can we do that on every single book
oh we can't who did that
oh relax you're fine dude it's just a
book
it's just a book don't act like you're
injured
he acted so mad
Place hello okay wait now what are we
supposed to do accio again also
or is that it
they're just flying around now on their
own
okay whoa whoa
Overexposed piece of paper right you can
barely see it
couple steps needed ah okay
couple steps needed to catch the snitch
no I'm really not listening to you so
let's find Neville no I wasn't trying to
talk to you Ron
I'm actually trying to talk to that
portrait
I'm right here dude I'm looking at you
I'm looking at you is that the portrait
talking
yeah I know this one was longer than
goblet for sure Mary I guess if you want
100 everything it'd be longer too
I'll bring the table over you really you
have to bring the table over
I guess you stand on the table then hold
on we're gonna knock out a few
gryffindors here
or can you just like
why can't you just stand in the chair
fully remove the arm chair I was about
to say
I'm up here
nope nope no Perry
okay right okay now I'm I'm starting to
get used to the aiming a little bit
how this targeting works thanks to
inspector there nope get back down Harry
get back down
and get over how small this common room
is man
all right there we go
locked on now
sorry Hermione I know that was like
right in the face are you listening
listening yes I'm trying to get out
there
time listen I've got a story that you
lost in here now I've managed to lose my
stitch in one of the portraits around
here you find myself you already know
where it is
us deal
we already know where it is then what do
I do just like tell you
okay so the snitch was
right there with that guy
wait hold on come on Target Target
Target
it's not targeting anything over here
that we need it to Target
I wonder if I need to uh
you don't tell me that we got to bring
the chair or the table over here excuse
me there we go excuse me
on your head how's that oh God you've
got my snitch did you call me
yeah we got it inspector
oh he's going he's going in
going all over to try and get it
all right so now what do we get to do
with that that's the question
or does it just give you more okay
[Music]
for a long time oh my gosh Myrtle I know
I know I haven't
I know
Myrtle is so I mean she just wants me to
spend every day in that secret room
all right that's good that's good okay
so let's see
let's go into our map here
see if we've got anything okay yeah
Neville we need to find Neville in the
room of requirement I think we're going
to start training up our
the snitch just knocked the chair over
the physics are a little bit weird
they are weird
hold on
so now I guess it's just gonna keep
flying around in here can you just grab
it imagine if you could just walk up and
grab it
oh come on get it
all right let's see if there's anything
updated on this board here oh there is I
could do that
uh I really didn't Ron I really didn't
but
can we not read that
oh there we go
can't really read what it's saying
though
okay guess you can't do anything with
that yet
Myrtle is the obsessive ex-girlfriend
right in the hypology greenhouse oh no
after what we just went through with
Goblet of Fire I am worried to go to the
greenhouses
okay they want me go this way
nope all right so we gotta wait on this
yeah wait on the staircase here
yeah so we finished up Goblet of Fire
this morning guys which it was rough but
we did it
I say it was rough it wasn't as bad as I
was afraid it was gonna be
I mean most of the game works there was
nothing totally game breaking in there
so
step slowly and walk sure or else you'll
fall to the floor all right
greenhouses are much more cozy and less
stressful nice that's what I'm hoping
for
oh yeah we did unlock the the Hufflepuff
guy oh
wait hold on Mary where was he I think
he's right down here
there he is
okay
I just want to see I just want to see
what happens
member of The Proud House of Hufflepuff
this guy's voice
I had word you helped member of The
Proud House of Hufflepuff Hey where's my
you said my reward where is it Dragon's
egg
he give me
was there something I was supposed to
get the first time
ah Transfiguration Courtyard and looks
like this is
taking us where we need to go
extremely Posh for Hufflepuff
all right in here oh dude can we cast
incendio on these now
oh you can't
oh maybe defendo later
yeah it does look like they'll have a
little rip right there in the middle
all right fine no incendio you don't
want me setting fire to the tapestries I
see
you've been guarding Leviosa them no
no really
oh it's not working for me
nope not what I was trying to do
only certain tapestries no way probably
the one that I commented on earlier oh
Secret
all right 95 to the next upgrade oh and
we got some stuff we can repair oh here
oh that's not creepy at all
cover him up
what just happened
this thank you thank you he's one of
them I'm sure he is come through quickly
next time say flaming earwigs oh another
secret right there
flaming earwigs
flaming earwigs ah they're everywhere
all right I know this is not the way
we're supposed to go but
okay yeah fifth four oh I do remember
this area in the game
oh hold on let's get this right here
another Secret
I know that eye was so creepy maybe
that's why they covered it up
just looking around at everything
man I'm already like feeling such a
sense of getting sidetracked in this
game
I can't imagine what it's gonna be like
with Legacy you guys
can't imagine
they're watching us they're all watching
us they're all watching us if you
all right so I want to continue on I'm
gonna go where we're supposed to be
going
oh this is definitely gonna be incendio
right nice plan
Professor will go mad we'll help you
sort it out oh thanks Harry I've been
using incendio to burn it away but I
can't cast it fast enough for my own all
right it's a little teamwork here a
little teamwork incendio
there we go work together guys
nice
we've done it that's some more inside we
haven't done it oh my gosh it's
everywhere
yeah oh my goodness the back to back to
back hydrates I think that might hold on
that might finish off my Cherry Coke
here
yep that finished it off
burning it
he likes murdering insects
wait why can we not please
please don't hold on it's not working
maybe we have to go like in a little bit
further
examine this first here
I don't use this one so protect the
Philosopher's Stone
right you are Ron right you are indeed
[Music]
is that it what nothing happens
Akio okay
no incendio
the pulso repair
like repair the glass
okay
why isn't able bad at herbology true all
right now let's see if we
there we go got a better
come on I need you guys to help me
why is it not
are they not helping me fast enough or
something what's going on
okay there we go that one's gone
burn it away burn it away oh posture
check posture check
stretch a little bit
bend the knee spin the knees since we're
in our
standing position right now don't fall
that's the right level did Hermione tell
you I'd found a place for the D.A to
practice yeah where is it on the seventh
floor the room of requirement just
follow me
all right well let's see what's in this
little
container right here first
I'm pressing Square
what
I'm pressing Square why is it not doing
anything
what am I missing
press square to examine
oh you have to wait for that actually I
hope I never have to eat that again
having gills once was enough thanks you
have almost 10K saving I removed the 10K
what did I even have as the 10K
I do not remember I had to take a lot of
them away because they just didn't fit
with what we
what we're currently doing on the
channel there's a lot of stuff that's
like more suited to multiplayer games
and stuff
a hundred push-ups oh my gosh there's no
way I could do that
yeah no wonder I took that off
no wonder I took that off
all right so what am I missing here
okay let's see
what are we supposed to do with this
there's got to be a way to do something
okay so you can't
Take the bucket with dirt first
is that this one
oh no we just had
just emote only again oh yeah that needs
to be our new ten thousand Nico that's
gonna have to be our ten thousand one
right there
although technically I think mods could
do that anytime
it is a good mechanism
if chats like going crazy or something
why is it not like it's not letting me
unless unless inspector could have been
talking about
maybe we need to bring this out
nope
all right what about in here anything in
here
jeez
it hurt my ears actually
get away get away
all right so it's not letting me
okay we're locked on right there
okay maybe the pulsive maybe accurate
Maybe reperto
fine incendio
all right I'm done
I'm done
oh the ones is that the one that's one
shot girl emotes I love it Nico
a love one shot girl my uh my son she's
a family friendly streamer too so it's
one my son and I can watch together
he's also super into fortnite now she
plays a lot of fortnite as well
Okay so
so move this one
all right now
I gotcha
what what
foreign
maybe I just need to drop it like right
inside of it
[Music]
all right you guys can't say even if you
know how to do this you can't say this
is intuitive
this is not intuitive
all right it's over it's over it's been
disabled
need to hover it over them so like wait
just sit it right here
why is it like I'm not even moving my
controller and it keeps moving
okay is my oh dude maybe my analog stick
has like drift or something
because it is totally moving on its own
okay wait
let's get like right here
why are you moving on your own
it worked
that little that's it
oh my goodness that little
oh okay there is a little I see a little
dirt in there now
Harry lock on dude lock on
all right now
water water
oh my gosh
oh my gosh dude
now due to all four oh no please tell me
you're joking you're not joking are you
you're not joking
all right well let's just do that first
just get them all filled with dirt first
like see it's it's it's right on there
oh there it goes there it goes there it
goes I actually see it this time
wow
I also wish he could walk
while I'm casting the spell
maybe if you can if you hold down a
button or something
foreign
I don't even know what that is Nico
don't even know what that is okay those
are both full somehow they already got
full all right drop you over here
that's a command
what in the world
Wingardium Leviosa
I have no idea what that could be
referring to
Nico no idea
foreign
come on how much water do you need
this is like the mimbleless mimbletonia
isn't it
that's a command why
say watery kid from Hogwarts Legacy oh
dude the same Enchanted watering can
that Waters no matter what oh here
Myrtle she's gonna tell me to come back
Secrets real oh secret room Harry I
don't want to
no I don't like I'm good I'm good just
exploring
I'm good just exploring
Harry Potter studio tour video times
Greenhouse where you pull up the
mandrakes oh that's awesome my wife and
I did one in the uh
it was the Harry Potter exhibition in
New York several years ago but it was um
like movie props and stuff I don't
remember anything about the the
mandrakes though
Kim de Pulsa the weird beehive looking
things on the ceiling oh
I have to go back
but not right now not right now dude
Myrtle's like I mean every time you
unlock something new I think she's gonna
start reminding you
gotta start reminding you oh by the way
all right where's our footprints
hold on okay this way yep
oh let's talk to you
okay you're asleep so we've gotta find
the other side
film set in London oh that's awesome
that is awesome
all right so let's go ahead and I
thought I saw a spot in the wall right
there
hey this way
hello Neville you've really got to need
it just think how much we need a room to
practice him we need to show that toad
umbrage I need to show people how to
fight against Voldemort see I told you
foreign
there we go all right so we're in I
guess this is when the uh the da is
officially formed
oh man look at this cutscene
look at this cutscene
[Music]
mini version of the WB
any version of it in LA fun but short oh
nice like Hogwarts wants us to fight
back
find the others and tell them where the
room is then we can start to practice
find the others tell them where the room
is
all right we could do that we could do
that
the soft glow everything has is crazy
yeah this is straight from the my PS3 as
well on the notice board which was yeah
it was it was like full HD full 1080 HD
and we can start with them
I've been trying to learn protego but I
can't seem to get it right Could you
teach it to us yes of course I will
Neville Armani have you got the spell
book
it can be tricky let's see so at this
point every portrait can now be unlocked
and you can freely explore Hogwarts to
your liking nice
okay what is she doing over this one up
twice wait isn't that the same thing as
the pulso
do as I do oh yeah that's the pulso and
also
what but I'm sure I'll remember I am so
confused
was that not
it's different because it's combat right
so it's not it doesn't seem like it's a
timing thing you just cast it before
they
hit you with the spell
well her Mighty teaches us that we teach
devil right like this was Harry's thing
in the book right the one thing that he
kind of had on Hermione is like
defense against the dark arts you know
that's like the one thing he was uh
better than her at okay so now I guess
we're gonna have to go and find the
other members of the D.A
oh and we got the little Mark right here
that's pretty cool
so let's Zoom back in oh they had the
picture of Cedric up there too
all right so both the Weasley twins
Colin creevey Dennis creevy I saw on
there
Justin Finch fletchley lavender Brown
Terry boot
okay but I want to see this comment from
protego Works only in the battle mode oh
yeah yeah
yep oh do they all show up on the map
now
that's super handy
they do
all right so
wait McGonagall
okay that said mini Quest
it's like wait McGonagall is in the D.A
in this game are you kidding me
Severus Snape Snape's in the D.A okay
that's interesting all right let's go
you know what
let's go with our boy Zacharias
I'm gonna go get him first
go the untraditional route you know like
people going in the alphabetical order
we're going to start start with the Z's
here
all right let's see if we can go find
Zachariah so this way
oh Nick oh no what are you trying to
distract me this time have you been up
to the
future
yo oh
he's concerned about something teachers
being there is interesting yeah I guess
they have like their own little Quest
just kind of cool
and also Ginny concerned about something
in the common room
which we may should just go do that
because she is well let's get let's get
this one first because Jenny's gonna be
a member as well
so then we can just go go find her after
this or wait we're already on the
seventh floor yeah it only makes sense
it only makes sense to just go ahead and
find Ginny now
yeah look how close we are
very close so we'll just go ahead and do
this now
wait you
thought that'd be crazy if it's already
that point
[Music]
that would be really jumping ahead right
let's see
all right Jenny what do you got for us
umbre just confiscated someone okay here
we go filmed things they're bottles of
Love Potion a lot of friend George doing
with love potions
potion you troll it's doxy venom for the
skiving snack boxes we've got to get
those bottles back or Fred and George
will be expelled their numbers is
storeroom oh can you dude we're getting
all kinds of missions thrown at us sorry
imagine from the boys dormitory
okay wait can I also like recruit you to
the D.A right now oh no I'll fetch it
from the boy's door she's like no
D.A what are you talking about no we've
got to do this first
all right fine
okay which side
this side
I do not remember how the invisibility
cloak works at all in this game
gotta complete their Quest
to recruit the D.A members
it's Trevor look at him over there
all right
many West Ham posters as he normally
does
Oh I thought that was my stuff
sorry Dean
is it in here maybe
Mrs Weasley go mad if she saw that mess
nope okay
I love that you you're getting like
you're getting rewarded for it snooping
through people's things like ooh what's
wrong got in here Dean okay I'm gonna
mess with Dean's things now
wait where is our
where is it
where is the invisibility cloak are you
serious right now
oh there it is
I love this thing right by the Frog
20 seconds oh they're all under it
oh this is weird
this is really weird just like a glow
you do still see their Footprints hey
hey what was that
we're here Jenny
I have a good one inspector enjoy your
your meal whatever it is for you dinner
lunch
RPG gonna take over for the back seating
all good
I guess we're just supposed to go I
thought we needed to tell Jenny like Hey
we're going after them
but apparently not
and I just so appreciate the no loading
screens though
so appreciate not having loading screens
oh you can still run
it's kind of crazy but it works
oh no
yep gotta go back go back
12 a.m for you inspector oh my goodness
[Music]
yeah we also need to remember at some
point to do all the portraits I'll
probably save that for next time
try to get all the portraits and all the
shortcuts so that will
hopefully speed all the exploration up
hey wait do we want to go straight now
yeah
looks like it
[Music]
hold on is this actually telling us
where to go I don't think it is I gotta
Mark Umbridge
yeah dude
have a good one silver thanks for being
here and hanging out
[Music]
and okay so we are still going
the right way
all right that's pretty funny that they
have them like
when they run into each other and stuff
okay let's see
this way nope
no come back
come back staircase
Rogers map it's like the Dada classroom
oh wait what we just like to work though
right because we picked where Umbridge
is
okay third floor
go in here
it's so eerie but it doesn't have any
sound or anything
oh we are moving now we are moving
invisibility cloak or not they are
pretty Speedy see if you can bump into
people
[Music]
now see that's so fun what a nice touch
they're like what is going on
there's Harry with his invisibility
cloak again
why they added the extra footsteps when
you're wearing the cloak I guess it's to
like try and help you
see where you are or something
but I almost wish they would have just
had like
I mean actually you but just you're a
little more transparent like this is
almost it just looks like we're this
Spirit right now just this floating
spirit
okay almost there
careful I hope she doesn't make us clean
anymore here we go dude I know I see one
more of ours gotta get Fred and George's
Things
we are at orb
we'll have to find a way to distract
them something that gets them away from
umbridge's door okay something that gets
them away from umbridge's door
it's right here maybe
well it said we can't cast spells under
this right
can't cast spells
oh the vases
break this one
oh no no don't come at me
is that guy going back
dude they went back way too quick
all right I think I got a better way to
do it
if we go here
break that I hope she didn't why do we
not even hear there's no sound effect
you can run I don't guess they care
about sound I was trying to be quiet but
they totally don't care about the sound
notice that the
the door just opened
oh look at all this stuff
it's a wonder there are still things
left golden Trio under the cloak your
sleep paralysis
Venom oh now you can use accio Hermione
the book earlier it wouldn't work
but now was that it is that all we need
I don't feel like that was it but
I guess it is they said let's go
I love how they don't care about sound
and I'm just gonna open this door
and she's just like whatever
oh man Hermione
are they back over here again
oh what in the world oh they're cleaning
they're cleaning
she's gonna lay a cast accio when the
plot allows it exactly
go back in here
she can't blame them either they
wouldn't get blamed if they weren't
involved in this okay this is weird
though the cutscene come on with them
under the cloak
they're still under the cloak in a
cutscene
oh man
that's too funny
all right we're back
oh that's kind of cool it just puts you
instantly back here all right now do we
just go and put the cloak back is that
what we do
let's see here
there we go
all right now will you join the DHS
so is that available anytime if so
that's pretty cool that you could just
go up there anytime and grab the cloak
oh my goodness Ron just get out of the
way dude trying to find the door here
that's all
controls they're so wonky
all right down we go down we go
right yes let's go Ginny George and tell
them to be more careful Doris is using
those special herbs at the Ministry
Center
I can't see a door open
mom would send oh man Weasley how dare
you let your brothers be expelled from
school yo that's pretty good Jenny
see you at the D.A okay so that worked
that was her Mission all right you've
recruited five of 28 Dia members in the
room of requirement let's go dude
all right so I guess you have to
hold on let me make sure I haven't seen
any auto save
oh
no I don't want to quit is there do I
need to manually save somewhere guys
right there it is I just totally missed
it I think there's an auto save too
though
okay yeah it's Auto saving all right I'm
just going to save in a separate slot
just in case one of them gets corrupted
or just in case the auto save wasn't
recent enough
oh man show next yeah we could do Cho
next I think it's gonna be it though for
today
but yeah thank you guys all so much hope
you all have a fantastic rest of your
week and I will talk to you again soon
thanks for being here guys